mais vous le disiez hélè dans les titres
nous revenons d'abord sur le discours de
politique générale de Gabriel hatal 19
jours après sa nomination le Premier
ministre a pris la parole à l'Assemblée
nationale à 15h un discours très attendu
par les différentes organisations
syndicales agricoles même s'il a
effectivement évoqué le malaise des
agriculteurs Gabriel hatal est
majoritairement revenu sur les réponses
qu'il avait déjà apporté plus de
contrôle du respect de la loi égalim et
des marchandises en provenance de
l'étranger les aides PAC versées avant
le 15 mars où le versement dans les plus
breevs délais des aides à l'installation
des jeunes agriculteurs alors est-ce que
ces annonces ont convaincu les
agriculteur on va justement leur poser
la question un rassemblement est
toujours en cours place Jean jores à
tour on y retrouve d'ailleurs romain
dalallville
ouis bonsoir hlè bonsoir Aurélien
bonsoir à tous et à toutes en effet la
placeage Jean jores alors que le
rassemblement était prévu de se
retrouver à partir de 18h30 place de la
préfecture où le préfet reçoit
actuellement les organisations
syndicales et les partenaires sociaux du
monde agricole des négociations qui
continuent à l'heure où je où je vous
parle ici PL Jean jorè allez une
cinquantaine de tracteurs ce soir
l'agriculteur a une âme de musicien au
klaxon de ton on a reconnu dés air de
Scatman ou encore de joyeux
anniversaires aussi une âme d'artificier
he des feux d'artifice continu et vous
entendez de pétaradé ici place jeanjorès
un peu plus loin au niveau du bras zéro
on est plutôt sur une enceinte avec de
la musique techno et de la mousse il y a
désormais de la mousse dans la fontaine
ici je ne sais pas mais on dirait que
les jeunes agriculteurs sont prêts pour
une soirée mousse à base de musique je
suis justement avec le président des
Jeunes Agriculteurs d'indrloir Benjamin
gelan bonsoir bonsoir à tous euh on
vient en effet vous voir après les
annonces de Gabriel Atal vous dénoncez
depuis le début du
mouvement les accords transatlantiques
les accords commerciaux en particulier
le mercosour aujourd'hui Gabriel Atal
annonce que il y aura des closes miroir
si bien que les partenaires devront
avoir les mêmes législations que par
exemple les agriculteurs français vous y
croyez non difficile à y croire parce
que hors de l'Union Européenne aucun
pays ne répond aux normes que nous on
produit en France on a des normes
surtout sur les phytosanitaires sur les
productions aucun produit ne peut être
plus de qualité que chez nous c'est
d'ailleurs l'honneur des agriculteurs
français un honneur mais que vous
aimeriez vous voir retrouver si j'ose
dire dans bah dans vos salaires
évidemment on aimerait queon vive
beaucoup mieux de notre métier et que
nos produits soi beaucoup mieux
valorisés aujourd'hui on est un peu
triste que les Français qui vont en
grande surface préfèrent plutôt prendre
un cochon issu de l'import hors Union
Européenne
qui est beaucoup moins cher que notre
produit de qualité issu de la France al
en effet les les grandes surfaces c'est
aussi l'enjeu de la loi
égalim dans les négociations en effet
entre le monde agricole et les grands
distributeurs donc ce qu'on retrouve
dans les grande surface pour le coup
Gabriel Atal a annoncé qu'après la loi
égalim que maintenant il y aurait plus
de contrôle au sein justement des
négociations de la loi é Galim entre le
monde agricole et les distributeurs
oui mais la loi éalim a déjà été très
longue à mettre en place et c'est pas
avec seulement 100 contrôleurs de plus
qu'on va faire respecter les lois donc
plus de contrôle pour la loi Galim vous
dénonciez finalement plus de contrôle
dans les fermes est-ce que là le c'est
encore l'enjeu ce soir je suis pas sûr
mais enfin le plus gros du travail il
est plutôt à faire sur ce qu' on importe
des pays étranger plutôt que sur nous
nos produits de qualité en France alors
que le préfet continue de recevoir vos
collègues en particulier de la FNSEA
parce que les j sont issus de la
FNSEA qu'est-ce que vous là vous
attendez désormais après les nouvelles
annonces de Gabriel àal qu'est-ce que
vous attendez de plus plus on en attend
tellement plus parce que il nous en a
donné pas beaucoup depuis la semaine
dernière et aujourd'hui son discours
d'aujourd'hui j'entends exactement le
même discours que vendredi dernier donc
évidemment qu'on attend plus et qu'on
continuera de manifester malheureusement
tant qu'on aura pas plus de réponse donc
je vous le disais Hélène et Aurélien
l'ambiance se passe actuellement plan je
reste place de la préfecture pour tout
vous avouer il y a trois tracteurs qui
ont renversé du fumier ça sent le cheval
comme on dit place de la préfecture
statut co de votre côté si bien que les
actions vont continuer oui évidemment et
on est content de rester avec proche de
nos citoyens on a depuis ce midi on a
pris le temps de discuter avec les gens
de tour on a fait discuter on a fait
déguster nos produits locaux et on
continuera jusqu'à ce soir 22h de
communiquer avec les citoyens et pour le
coup pas de lois et Galim on est du
producteur au consommateur ce soir PL
Jean
jores merci Romain et merci à Lucas
Chupin qui vous accompagnait sur ce
duplexe et en début de journée avant les
annonces du Premier ministre les
agriculteurs poursuivaient leurs action
oui ce midi une soixantaine de tracteurs
ont envahi le centreville de tour pour y
stationner et proposer romain en parlait
une dégustation place Jean jorè mais
avant cela un autre convoi avait décidé
de bloquer les entrées d'un parking de
supermarché retour sur ces deux actions
avec Aurélie
Renault il est 13h et il est désormais
impossible d'entrer sur le parking de ce
supermarché de tour nord 30 agriculteurs
non syndiqués venus du nord du
département bloquent les issues avec les
tracteurs le supermarché reste ouvert la
plupart des clients indique être
solidaire donc moi je trouve que je
trouve que c'est une bonne initiative de
venir ici c'est mieux peutêtre pas mieux
que les rond-points mais ça empêche les
gens de venir et je trouve que c'est une
bonne une bonne initiative parce que que
quand on voit ce qu'on achète c'est même
plus français je suis descendu de
voiture pour leur dire que je les
remerciis d'avoir bloqué ce centre
commercial parce que je suis venu samedi
et dans l'entrée du centre commercial
juste devant c'était marqué des fraises
d'Égypte et moi ça m'a choqué vraiment
beaucoup en disant ils se moquent du
monde ces magasins les agriculteurs
dénoncent en effet les normes drastiques
auxquelles ils sont astreints comparé à
d'autres pays les gens ils vont manger
tout tout tout tout tout un tas de de
trucs de trucs étranger ou que c'est pas
respecté et nous en France ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est qu'alure d'aujourd'hui
on est tout le temps tout le temps normé
normé il faut tout le temps restreindre
notre production il y a toujours quelque
chose tout le temps tout le temps tout
le temps au même moment plus de 60
tracteurs prennent possession de la
place jeanjorès à l'appel de la
FDSEA pommes jus de fruits riettes sont
auert au tourangeau les agriculteurs
veulent mettre en avant l'importance de
l'achat responsable l'achat local ils
sont aussi par leur acte d'achat
responsable de l'avenir de l'agriculture
qu's ont leur rôle à jouer dans notre
avenir bah les gens regardent le leur
portefeuille donc effectivement c'est
quand même moins cher dans la grande
surface mais bon quand on peut c'est
c'est vraiment bien de de le faire je
fais attention quand j'achète un produit
à regarder d'où il vient et je n'achète
pas du poulet pas cher et cetera donc
j'achète plutôt chez les
artisans les acteur devrait rester plage
jeanjorès jusqu'à 22h ce
mardi